all right good afternoon everyone and
Welcome to our in-person and virtual uh
participants in today's press briefing
uh to my left in the room we are
grateful to have the under secretary of
defense for policy Dr Colin call we'll
have roughly 30 minutes today for our
discussion uh and we will endeavor to
get through as many questions as
possible in the briefing room and online
if I do not call you out by your name in
your outlet if you can please introduce
yourself when asking your question and
with that I will toss it to Dr Cole
great thanks Dave
good afternoon everybody I'm deeply
grateful for another opportunity to
address you all today this time ahead of
my travel to the NATO Summit in Vilnius
with the president and with secretary
Austin next week and before my eventual
transition from leading our policy
apparatus here in the Pentagon which has
been the honor of my lifetime at such a
critical period in the Global Security
environment
as you know NATO NATO leaders will
convene in Vilnius at a crucial juncture
for transatlantic security
17 months into Russia's unlawful
aggression against Ukraine we bear
witness to the tragedy unfolding in the
heart of Europe a tragedy that Vladimir
Putin can end at any time as by every
measure his objectives have not been
fulfilled and they will not be fulfilled
in Ukraine
the nations of NATO stand United
alongside nations from around the world
showing an unwavering determination to
provide unprecedented support to Ukraine
while simultaneously strengthening the
alliance's own deterrence and defense
during our meetings in Vilnius we will
build upon years of adaptation charting
the course for a more safe secure and
prosperous world and refining our next
steps in response to the ongoing crisis
in Ukraine
today the United States also continues
to demonstrate its enduring commitment
to Ukraine with the announcement of a
new drawdown of military assistance to
provide Ukraine's forces with additional
Munitions weapons and equipment needed
to defend their country and push back on
Russia's war of aggression
with the announcement of this 42nd
presidential drawdown package the United
States has committed more than 41.3
billion dollars in military assistance
since Russia first launched its
unprevoked and brutal war against
Ukraine on February 24 2022 and more
than 44.1 billion in military assistance
since Russia's initial invasion of
Ukraine back in 2014.
some of the capabilities in today's 800
million dollar drawdown package include
155 millimeter artillery rounds
including Dual Purpose improved
conventional Munitions or depictums and
105 millimeter artillery rounds
additional Munitions for Patriot air
defense systems and ammunition for high
Mobility artillery rocket systems or
highmars
additional Bradley infantry fighting
Vehicles additional Striker armored
personnel carriers
Precision aerial ammunitions
demolition Munitions and systems for
obstacle clearing
and various spare parts and operational
sustainment equipment
with this announcement we will be able
to provide Ukraine with hundreds of
thousands of additional artillery
ammunition immediately
this decision will ensure we can sustain
our support for Ukraine by bridging us
to a point where we are producing
sufficient artillery ammunition on a
monthly basis across the coalition
we recognize the complexities here which
is why I want to quickly provide a few
additional pieces of information on
dpicm
first Russia has been using cluster
Munitions Munitions indiscriminately
since the start of this war in order to
attack Ukraine by contrast Ukraine is
seeking dpicm rounds in order to defend
its own Sovereign territory
second compared to Russian cluster
Munitions the dpicm rounds we will
provide Ukraine have an extremely low
failure or dud rate
the dpicm ammunition we are delivering
to Ukraine will consist only of those
with a dud rate less than 2.35 percent
compare that to Russia which has been
using cluster Munitions across Ukraine
with dud rates of between 30 and 40
percent
during the first year of the conflict
alone Russia fired cluster Munitions
deployed from a range of weapon systems
have likely expended tens of millions of
submunitions or bomblets across Ukraine
third we're working with Ukraine to
minimize the risks associated with the
decision the Ukrainian government has
offered us assurances in writing on the
responsible use of dpicms including that
they will not use the rounds in civilian
populated Urban environments and that
they will record where they use these
rounds which will simplify later
demining efforts
Ukraine also has committed to
post-conflict demining efforts to
mitigate any potential harm to civilians
the United States has already invested
more than 95 million dollars in
Ukraine's demining activities and we
will provide more support to help
Ukraine mitigate the impacts of cluster
munition use by both sides in this
conflict
and fourth and this is critical by
providing Ukraine with dpicm artillery
ammunition we will ensure that the
Ukrainian military has sufficient
artillery ammunition for many months to
come in this period the United States
our allies and partners will continue to
ramp up our defense industrial basis to
support Ukraine for the past year and a
half
President Biden has been clear that we
will support Ukraine for as long as it
takes
I want to commend the tireless efforts
of the department our allies and our
partners in delivering this historically
unprecedented level of security
assistance
throughout the kremlin's vicious war of
choice the Ukrainian forces have
effectively leveraged assistance and
shown outstanding bravery and skill
Ukraine's fight is a marathon not a
Sprint so we will continue to provide
Ukraine with the Urgent capabilities
that it needs to meet the moment as well
as what it needs to keep itself secure
for the long term from Russian
aggression
finally on a personal note as I enter my
last week as under secretary of defense
for policy I want to thank the hundreds
of Patriots and professionals across OSD
policy I believe they are the finest
national security organization in the
business for all that they have done to
support Ukraine strengthen our alliances
and Partnerships around the world and
work tirelessly every day alongside our
military and interagency colleagues to
keep America safe and with that I'll
pass the mic back to Dave and look
forward to your questions okay thanks
sir we'll go first to Tarka AP
much for doing this a couple of
questions
you could talk about the dud rate there
seems to be some questions about how the
U.S knows that its own Munitions that
will be provided will have such a low
dud rate and have you been able to
assure allies that these Munitions won't
cause excessive civilian harm
and then secondly is the primary reason
that the cluster Munitions are being
used now because there is so much strain
on the 155 millimeter pile yeah those
are those are important questions so
look we're aware of reporting and I've
seen some things uh in in the Press over
the last 24 hours
you know that references various DOD
studies which analyze the dud rates of
older versions of dpicms there are lots
of different variants I think as we
talked about you know the Russians are
you know a cluster munition is not a
cluster munition they're they're big
differences uh between them many of
those studies that have been referenced
at least the ones that I've seen in the
Press were based on testing completed in
the 1980s and many of the dpicms of
those variants have since been
demilitarized we're not providing those
variants of DPI CMS to Ukraine instead
we'll be providing our most modern
dpicms with dud rates assessed to be
under 2.35 percent demonstrated through
five comprehensive tests conducted by
the Department of Defense between 1998
and 2020. so we're confident in those uh
in those numbers I will also say how
they're used matters
and that's one of the reasons why as we
deliberated on this and look this this
was a a decision it took us a while to
come to and all the concerns that people
have raised the humanitarian concerns
what the reaction of allies and partners
would be what the reaction would be on
the hill all of these things were
debated and adjudicated within the
interagency but one of the things in
addition to the fact that you know we
weren't providing
uh cluster Munitions above the dud rate
that I I talked about was the assurances
that we uh got from the Ukrainian side
on this um we've gotten these assurances
in writing uh the secretary had an
opportunity to discuss this with
Minister reznikov yesterday and he
reiterated those assurances and as I
said in my opening those assurances are
essentially that they would not use
dpicm in urban areas that are populated
by civilians and that there would be a
careful accounting of where they use uh
these weapons that's going to matter for
future demining uh efforts I should also
say well none of us should minimize uh
this issue this is an issue the
ukrainians are going to have to Grapple
with regardless if if we had never made
a decision on dpicm the ukrainians would
be demining it's going to be a
generational effort because of uh the
amount of landmines anti-personnel
anti-tank mines cluster Munitions that
the Russians uh have been using so this
is an issue we have to tackle uh
regardless we're committed to helping
the the ukrainians uh do that you asked
about the primary reason I would I would
really point to two reasons one is the
urgency of the moment which is that uh
you know the ukrainians are in the midst
of their counteroffensive it's been a
it's been hard sledding because the
Russians had you know six months to dig
in and so those defensive belts that the
Russians have put in place in the East
and the South are hard
uh they'd be hard for any uh military uh
to punch through and so we want to make
sure that the ukrainians have sufficient
artillery to keep them in the fight in
the context of the current
counter-offensive and because things are
going a little slower than uh some had
hoped there are very high expenditures
of artillery rates so this is to make
sure uh that the ukrainians have the
confidence that they have what they need
but frankly also that the Russians know
uh that the that the ukrainians are
going to stay uh in in the game and then
the second point which is important is
we don't see this as a permanent
solution but rather a bridge we've
already substantially increased uh the
production of unitary 155 millimeter
rounds the Europeans and others are also
investing in their defense industrial
base that's good news and it's starting
to pay dividends but the reality is
we're going to need to build a bridge to
the point at which that capacity is
sufficient on a month-to-month basis to
keep the ukrainians in the artillery
fight the last point I will make is a
strategic one
um Vladimir Putin has a theory of
Victory okay his theory of Victory is
that he will Outlast everybody
he'll Outlast the ukrainians he'll
Outlast the United States he'll Outlast
the Europeans he'll Outlast the
International Community he will simply
Brute Force his way through this having
failed and kind of achieving a lightning
Victory he's now going to play the long
game that's why President Biden has been
clear that we're going to be with
Ukraine as long as it takes and why we
are signaling that we will continue to
provide Ukraine with the capabilities
that will keep them in the fight and
look I'm as concerned about the
humanitarian circumstance as anybody
uh but the worst thing for civilians in
Ukraine is for Russia to win the war uh
and so it's important that they don't
let's go Liz fox thank you for doing
this um when will these Munitions make
it into Ukraine and can you talk
specifically about what the strengths
are of using these cluster Munitions
um and are they going to be as effective
as the ones Russia has been using
well I mean I don't know I don't want to
draw comparisons between what they're
using it's their apples and oranges it's
the point that I made before a cluster
munition is not a cluster Mission these
are uh much more efficient uh weapons
because they have much lower uh dud
rates so
um the bad news about 30 to 40 percent
dud rates is that it creates a lot of
unexploded ordinance it also means it's
not generating the effects that they
that they want either so what you want
is uh for these weapons to generate the
effects that they were designed for and
in this context you know I think they
will help
um in some of these security belts that
the ukrainians are pushing against
against some of the dug in uh formations
that uh that the Russians have
um I think they will also be useful for
troop concentrations and concentrations
of armored vehicles and lighter-skinned
vehicles so they'll have uh they'll have
utility I think it's important that they
have a mix of capabilities it's not no
one uh capability is a is a solar bullet
so they have unitary 155 high explosive
rounds they have the Excalibur rounds
which are GPS guided uh they obviously
have the rocket systems that we have
transferred uh uh to them in the in the
form of gimler so it's really no one
thing is going to make a difference but
I think this gives them an extra arrow
in their quiver on the timing I'm going
to be going to be a little circumspect
for operational security uh reasons
um we have been pretty cautious about
talking about uh specific timelines the
one thing I will say is they will
deliver in a time frame that is relevant
for the counter offensive
great let's go Tony Bloomberg I had a
couple questions and um has the United
States ever used the dicm DPI cm in
combat I don't think they have so how
robust are our inventories and why were
these in why was these in the U.S
inventory anyway were these used to plan
for a North Korea Invasion kind of
scenario yeah I'll have to get back to
you on previous uses my understanding is
there were uses of dpicm uh back but it
may go back to the Gulf War but I may
but I may have that wrong so let's get
back to you uh on that
um I will say uh they're in our
inventories because there are a range of
contingency plans where this could be uh
where this could be useful
um but this is also an area where our
inventories are quite large and we are
not concerned that in the quantities we
would transfer to the ukrainians that it
would have a meaningful impact on our
Readiness for other contingencies if I'm
a Ukrainian squatter platoon leader
leader and going into areas where these
were these fired
How concerned I should I be that my my
troops may fall into these things and
get blown apart themselves I mean
frankly I think the the Graver concern
is that they uh Wander into a Russian
Minefield uh or uh areas where the
Russians have expended uh weapons with a
much higher dud rate
um I think that this is a reason though
a there were only transferring dpicm
with a very low dud rate there are
variants with higher dud rates they were
not they were not transferring and B why
it will be important for the ukrainians
to keep track of where they're firing uh
these things both for immediate uh Force
protection reasons and over the medium
to longer term for demining uh
operations in uh in kind of
post-occupation uh post-liberation uh
parts of Ukraine okay we're going to go
out to the line Michael Gordon Wall
Street Journal
uh thank you for Dr Kyle um uh sir
you've said that the Russians have um uh
used uh tens of millions of submunitions
in Ukraine I have two questions uh since
you've described this as a bridge how
many submunitions is the U.S now
providing uh planning to provide to
Ukraine say on a month-to-month basis uh
given is a bridge are you going to be
providing millions or hundreds of
thousands how many are you providing and
since the US has been so critical of the
Russian employment of um uh cluster
Munitions are there any additional steps
that you can identify to mitigate the
risks to civilians beyond the assurances
from the ukrainians is there going to be
special training is the U.S going to
monitor the dud rates on the battlefield
and oversee the areas where they're
employed there are some specific
additional steps the U.S will take to
reduce the risk of to civilians
thanks uh Michael so I'm not going to go
into specific numbers I will say in my
opening statement I I mentioned hundreds
of thousands we have hundreds of
thousands of these uh rounds available
below the dud rate threshold that I
mentioned but I'm not going to tip our
hand to the Russians about knowing
what's coming and what volume when I
will say we're confident that with this
inflow of dpicm in combination with the
unitary 155 rounds we continue to
provide that the ukrainians will be able
to sustain uh the artillery fight for
the foreseeable future which I said is
not only important in the moment for the
counter-offensive but to signal to
Vladimir Putin that he can't just uh
Outlast uh the the ukrainians
um look I I think we have been critical
of the Russian use of this and but in
large part for two reasons one because
the Russians have been indiscriminate in
their use of all kinds of weapons uh
they you know even their so-called
Precision guide ammunitions you know fly
into apartment buildings uh and hit
schools and so and they've been
indiscriminate in the usage of cluster
Munitions as well they're also using
weapons that are much older which much
with much higher dud rate and that's
that's uh much higher risk of collateral
damage uh even when they're not used uh
indiscriminately so as I said before I
think this is kind of an apples to
oranges comparison beyond the assurances
which I think we should take
meaningfully I mean in the in the in the
past when we have asked uh uh the
ukrainians to offer Us explicit
assurances they've stuck by those uh
assurances so I think we should give the
ukrainians the benefit of the doubt we
will of course be watching how the
ukrainians use these systems they will
be reporting uh their usage back to us
um uh and so we can always make
judgments later if we feel like those
assurances are not be are not being met
but I'm confident that the ukrainians
will be true to their word I'll also say
that like with every system that we
provide the ukrainians there will be uh
not just training but kind of coaching
and mentoring associated with this and I
think one of the reasons why the
ukrainians have been so effective in
employing uh the artillery they they
have had regardless of system is that uh
that they've received some coaching and
mentoring for the United States about
the best employment of that and so um
we'll continue to do that so one more
online we'll go to Lee sangmin of Radio
free Asia
are you there
okay let's come back to the room
Courtney
now on cluster munition question
actually one quick question did you say
have you said how many is in this first
so I'm not going to go into specific
numbers we talked about hundreds of
thousands of of uh of Munitions but I'm
not gonna just
stockpiles hundreds of thousands right
I'm not going to talk about how much in
each tranche all I'm going to say is we
have hundreds of thousands that are
available uh at this uh dud rate
um and that we believe the numbers and
our ability to flow them into Ukraine
will be sufficient to keep them not only
in the current fight but to build this
bridge uh to increase capacity on the
155 unitary rounds that means you're
gonna have more tranches this isn't just
a one-time delivery then I guess too
right I mean I don't want to prejudge
decisions that haven't been made since
at the end of the day these are
decisions the president of the United
you know the secretary recommends to the
president the president signs off on we
I will just say this we have the
capacity to continue uh to flow
additional rounds forward and if we were
to do so we have sufficient quantities
uh to be able to do the things I said
since have you here I'm
I've seen interactions with the Iranian
Navy and just give us a sense it seems
as if there's been like a small uptick
at least this week in these incidents if
you have any sense of why now
um why Iran is doing this they tend to
actions like this tend to be a response
to something yeah
uh well first of all it's not completely
clear
um and frankly it's not a very effective
message uh to uh essentially engage in
piracy on the high seas and shoot it uh
unarmed civilian uh Maritime uh craft I
think as you're all tracking essentially
there were two incidents uh in the in
the past a few days that occurred within
a few hours of each other the first
incident was a case in which an Iranian
vessel approached the Marshall Islands
flagged oil tanker the trf moss in the
Gulf of Oman the Iranian vessel Departed
the scene when uh the U.S Navy guided
missile destroyer USS McFall arrived and
then there was a second incident three
hours later where an Iranian vessel
closed uh within one mile and fired
multiple long bursts from small arms and
crew served weapons and the Navy
received a distress call from the
Bahamian flagged oil tanker Richmond
Voyager and the USS USS mcfaul responded
again why the Iranians are doing in this
at this moment is not not at all clear
to us I think it's a better question
left left to them but it's got the
highest attention of the department I'll
just say as a personal anecdote I don't
know if any of you are here on the
fourth of July for the fireworks display
it's a cool place to watch uh the
fireworks but as the 9 30 as the
crescendo of fireworks was occurring
over the mall I got a call on my cell
phone I was out on the lawn with my kids
uh it was and it was a sect have cable
saying that the secretary wanted to
convene a secure call with his senior
leadership team to discuss these issues
because the second incident was ongoing
and so for 45 minutes we were on the
phone the secretary of the chairman
General carrilla our navsent commander
uh working through what were the
Iranians doing where were our assets
what was the ship's Captain requesting
us to do what were we advising them to
do the mcfaul was steaming uh in that
direction the captain was advised by
navsen to redirect to enter Omani
territorial Waters and the a combination
of all of those decisions appears to
have warned the Iranians off so even
after taking some pot shots at the
Richmond Voyager we were successful in
in the Iranians leaving the area before
right before the McFall showed up I
mentioned that to say that just like
this has the highest attention of the
department uh we're gonna you know we
have I think uh General carrilla has
done a good job of moving around the
assets he already has at his disposal to
thicken our ability to respond to
incidents like this and I think the
proof is in the other night I think we
continue to work with our allies and
partners especially in the imsc which is
the international Maritime security
construct which some of you have
probably been out to fifth Fleet it runs
out of Bahrain I know you have uh uh
Courtney and so we'll continue to work
with our allies and partners not just in
the region but around the world like the
like the UK to try to thicken that out
because whatever the Iranians are trying
to do here I don't think we should
assume it'll be the last time they
let's go to the back room fatty Al
jazeer thank you thank you Dr call I
have two quick questions on the cluster
munition and one on Russia on the
cluster munition
um you mentioned five studies since 1998
until 2020 that proved you have in your
uh stockpile dot dot rate lower than
2.35 is the department willing to make
these studies available so experts can
verify the accuracy of the data second
one in in terms of
providing cluster munition is this
Administration breaking the law passed
by the Congress that uh prohibits the
the transfer of cluster munition that is
without uh level above one percent and
finally on Russia we've seen uh two
incidents lately uh in in Syria where
Russian aircraft according to the
Pentagon harassed uh U.S drones before
that we saw something happening
similarly in the Black Sea are you
certain that this Russia is kind of kind
of normalizing this behavior and is that
the OD willing to take any actions uh to
prevent Russia from continuing this type
of behavior thank you
sure so a bunch of things there on the
ver on the on the test itself I think at
this juncture because the tests
themselves are classified we won't be
releasing them but uh we'll take that
question uh uh question back presently
uh those tests uh those uh reports are
classified I can say this we have uh
high confidence uh in those numbers
based on five uh consecutive tests
um I also have high confidence that they
will be far more uh efficient and
discriminant than the cluster Munitions
that the Russians are using and I think
the Ukrainian assurances on top of that
um uh give me added confidence in that
I'll also say that it's not a good thing
for civilians in Ukraine or the
humanitarian situation in Ukraine for
Ukraine's counter-offensive to be
unsuccessful or for the Russians to be
more successful that seems like a recipe
for uh more humanitarian suffering so to
the degree that there's a utilitarian
calculus in this I think it's it's worth
thinking that through and I think that's
ultimately why even though this is a
decision that the admission registration
deliberated on
and that the president thought very
carefully about there was no
disagreement among the president's
principal advisors on whether we should
provide this system and that includes
across the Departments not just the
department of of Defense um are we
breaking the law we are not breaking the
law
um I would say first of all the the
prohibition against exporting above one
percent these Munitions are pretty close
to one percent but they're not at the
one percent level uh but the president
does have the authority uh to waive that
requirement on National Security grounds
and that's what he has done in this
instance there's no dispute that he has
that Authority it's in it's in law but
we also didn't make this as a unilateral
decision we've been having conversations
with uh informal conversations for weeks
uh with the hill I'm sure many of you
have had your own conversations with
members on both sides of the aisle on
the on the hill this is obviously a
capability that the ukrainians have been
asking for for a while and we continued
those consultations with the hill
and escalated them as we got closer to
this decision so it doesn't mean
everybody in Congress will uh will agree
but I think everybody will agree that it
was within the right of the president to
do this
um on the Syrian uh on the on the
Russian activities in Syria
yeah I mean I think we've seen we've
seen activities uh by the Russians uh
Air Force
um to encroach on kind of the informal
Arrangements we have uh with them about
deconflicting uh airspace
um I will say that it does concern us um
and I do think uh what we don't want to
be is in a situation where they are
normalizing Behavior where there can be
an incident
um you know it would it would be I think
significant if there was an incident
involving an uncrewed system
um it would be even more significant if
it involved a piloted aircraft so we
will continue to highlight uh when the
Russians engage in Reckless
unprofessional uh uh behavior in the
skies we will highlight for the world so
that when and if an incident happens
people will know who's at fault uh here
and we hope to dissuade the Russians
from continuing this pattern of behavior
because you know incidents and accidents
if they occur can you know can spin out
of control that's not in our interest
but it's also not in Russia's interest
uh so we'll continue to make that point
to them okay we're going to go out for
one more Eric Schmidt New York Times
yes uh Dr Carl you you acknowledge that
the uh the recruiting counter-offensive
is going slower uh than anticipated uh
contributing some of that to the Russian
defenses including minefields but you
could could you also discuss uh the
limitations of the combined arms
training uh the short duration training
that they got uh the ukrainians and to
what extent they've been able to uh
absorb that those that kind of training
and apply it in this kind of difficult
Battlefield situation thank you
yeah I mean first I think uh as the
Ukrainian leadership has said you know
this isn't a movie uh right so that this
is gonna it things are hard in real War
uh things are hard sometimes things go
faster than you think uh like in harkeev
uh last fall sometimes uh it's a slog uh
like it was in hears on uh last fall I
think when you're talking about uh
Eastern and Southern Ukraine uh the
Russians have had you know during the
winter neither side was standing still
right the ukrainians with our assistance
and the assistance of the allies and
partners we're building this mountain of
Steel for the counter-offensive the
Russians were digging in uh laying
minefields uh anti-anti tank uh
obstacles and barriers trench lines uh
and so uh we always knew it was going to
be uh tough
um Eric I think to your point about the
combined arms training I think we should
draw lessons at the end not in the mid
not in the middle and I think we're only
in the beginning of the middle uh and I
say that because
um yeah the the uh you know a number of
brigades went through training in
Germany and elsewhere by the United
States and our allies to get them ready
for this fight it was truncated relative
to you know what a U.S army unit might
might go through but I think the
ukrainians have regularly proved that
they can kind of step on the accelerator
pedal uh and be uh pretty proficient it
does of course uh you know it pushes
them out of their comfort zone a little
bit because uh this you know has them
employing fire and maneuver in a way
that's more familiar to Nato uh forces
than kind of forces that have a Soviet
Legacy and Soviet Doctrine uh behind
behind them
um so it is you know requiring them to
fight in different uh ways but
um I will say this I I am not
particularly I'm you know it is slower
than we had hoped again uh Ukrainian
officials have have said as much
um but the ukrainians have a lot of
combat power left
um and in fact the majority of their
combat power for this fight has not been
brought to bear and so what you're
seeing across the East and the south is
the ukrainians deliberately and not
understandably deliberately probing for
weak spots and I think the real test
will be when they identify weak spots or
create weak spots and generate a breach
how rapidly they're able to exploit that
with the combat power that they have in
reserve and how rapidly the Russians
will be able to respond and Eric I just
don't I don't know uh the answer is
either of those questions because we're
not at the point uh in the battle yet
okay we're going to come back in the
room for two more Phil
a quick follow on that I mean do you
think then that the ukrainians are
making effective use of the materials
the United States has provided or or not
yet and then I want to ask you about
progosian what do you what do you know
about him uh what is his status uh what
is he doing in in Russia uh what do you
think his future is
uh so on the effective use piece um
look this stuff is hard and uh and
especially if you're encountering it and
using techniques techniques procedures
and capabilities that you're not
familiar with I think the ukrainians are
doing their best I think they are
determined uh to liberate these areas
from Russian occupation I think the
Russians probably were more successful
in digging in more deeply than uh
perhaps was fully appreciated
um you know you you uh you know no plan
survives first contact with uh With the
Enemy so they uh they are moving
deliberately against the threat that's
there I would return to the point that
that I made I I think that it's too
early to judge how the counter offensive
is going one way or the other because
we're at the beginning of the middle
they they are still uh probing Uh
Russian lines in Russian areas uh for
weak spots and the real test will be
when they identify those how rapidly
they are able to exploit uh those weak
spots and we will continue to offer Our
advice uh where it's uh useful but at
the end of the day these are Ukrainian
choices because after all it's their
lives that are on the line it's their
territory that's that's on the line so
we can provide coaching advice mentoring
but at the end of the day they're going
to make the decisions uh that they
believe is right burgosian where he is
what he's up to I have no idea
um and so I and I really don't want to
speculate I see the same things that you
see you know it's clear that
um the Russian state is trying to
systematically dismay handle his Empire
and put peace Parts in different places
what the ultimate in-game Putin has for
uh progosian and the the remnants of
Wagner I think is still to be determined
but I I just don't want to speculate
about you know is he in Belarus is he in
St Petersburg or Moscow or somewhere
else I I don't know where he is let's
close with Jim garamone
sir thanks for uh thanks for doing this
and as this is our last chance to get
you uh at least in this position at this
time I'd like to broaden it a little bit
President Biden secretary Austin
secretary blank and many others say that
the U.S asymmetric advantage is its
network of allies partners and Friends
yet there are many Americans who really
believe that the United States should go
It Alone
and given your experience not only this
time but in your previous stints it with
the other administrations and here at
the Pentagon what do you tell people
like that and
what do you tell them that allies and
partners bring to uh to the collective
defense
yeah it's a it's a great question and um
look I think we've tested we've tried as
an Administration to test a proposition
right
um I don't think it's a partisan point
to say that you know there were at least
some in the previous administration that
didn't value our allies and partners in
quite the way that that we do it they're
they're at the center they're at the
center of our national security strategy
there at the center of international
defense strategy we do use these you
know fancy jargons like asymmetric
advantage and network of allies and
partners but what are really uh adds up
to and I think you know the average
person in a bar can understand is
international relations is a team sport
that the United States is the most
powerful country in the world we're the
most powerful country in the history of
the world
we have the best military in the world
we have the best military in the history
of the world as powerful as we are as
capable as our military uh uh is there
is no problem that comes across my deck
my desk where I say you know what would
make this easier if we had to do this
all by ourselves
right it's just it's not it's just like
you don't play basketball even if you're
Michael Jordan you like to have four
other bulls with you on the court sorry
that's a really old reference for uh but
I'm 52 so yeah you got me at least um
it's a team sport and you know you can
make that and people can get it but the
proof is in the pudding and that is look
we are you know how are we contending
with the greatest threat to the
geopolitical order since the uh end of
the Cold War maybe since the end of the
second World War
but by building a team in the first
instance uh you know Putin went into
this hoping that NATO would Buckle
weaken Frey shatter apart the exact
opposite has happened NATO was Stronger
the defense commitments are are going up
you're going to see manifestations of
that Unity I think this week uh in in
Vilnius our efforts to deter attacks on
the United States and our allies have
been bolstered not only by what we're
doing in Ukraine but what we've done to
strengthen the NATO alliance that makes
America safer that's not charity to
Europe that makes us safer from the
threat that Russia poses but also the
world that Russia's model of aggression
would impose uh on on the rest of us
and then you look in the indo-pacific
and there's a lot of focus in our
strategy documents on China as the
pacing challenge that's what we call it
in the National defense strategy or our
most consequential strategic uh
competitor
we're not going to win that competition
on our own now we have to make
investments in ourselves which we are
that's why we've made investments in you
know the chips and science Act and the
infrastructure bill it's why we are
making massive investments in defense uh
modernization and why there's bipartisan
consensus around all of that but we are
not going to Best China in this
competition alone uh we need to get our
team together which is why I'm
extraordinarily proud of what this
Administration has accomplished what
this president what this secretary has
accomplished frankly what my team has
helped to accomplish in things like
August or the posture changes in
Australia or the historic posture
changes in Japan or the historic posture
changes in the Philippines or the
deepening of our alliance with the ROK
on display during the recent State visit
or the Strategic opportunity of a
lifetime we have with India on display
during the most recent uh India uh State
visit by Prime Minister Modi we are
putting real points on the board because
we are we are leaning in to our existing
alliances and building out our our
Partnerships and if we are going to win
the rest of the 21st century that's how
we are going to win alongside our
teammates
Dr Cole thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen thanks for attending today